okay this is the police officer we
believe an undercover police officer
he's right in the middle of that group
he has been remonstrating with the
protesters it seems to be a little
caramelized some of the protesters have
their arm around his shoulder he seems
to be in some pain I would suggest or
certainly catching his breath giving
what has happened to him he's leaning
forwards and he's trying to gather his
thoughts others around him covering that
faces either with masks because they're
worried about teargas
or they don't want to be recognized for
whatever reason they are wearing masks
at the moment it does seem to be a
little calm and I believe he is in a
very precarious positions shall we say
his hands are a cable tied in front of
him some of the yellow helmets are
around ten people are speaking to him
he's trying to be calm but struggling
for breath on occasion I know that you
are holding in that direction what does
the atmosphere I feel like where you are
it feels feels colder than it did about
half an hour ago
[Music]
it's very jumpy cave there's a guy just
next to us who yeah now we're almost
here here at this at the the alleged
police officer yeah we see those helmets
the can't tell if they're there are
medics that are in there
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
very good is it okay I'm sorry I'm just
trying to get
[Music]
yeah you said I came here now and ka so
you can you can see this being
[Music]
yeah I'm really sure I mean he has been
here a really long time
see
[Music]
[Applause]
so Stu I think they're going through his
blog I know they're shouting a lot there
at the moment so you can't really hear
what's going on they're going through
his bag and looking at some of the
things that are inside it's a very tense
situation I don't know you can still
hear as perhaps you can give us an idea
of what people are saying on and what's
going to happen to this who we think is
an undercover police officer you said
they were two of them earlier one of
them has been freed by their colleagues
this guy as you said has been there for
several is now and is still surrounded
by the protesters who look as though
they're going nowhere at this stage
no they're not kay he's getting beaten
now there's people hitting him those I'm
trying to help them doing this is means
a few times
[Applause]
pretty interesting but no idea
others and stop fighting
[Applause]
sorry
it's more cable ties coming
[Applause]
what are they saying the transition
facility
[Music]
the guy who's wearing the red t-shirt
just
[Music]
okay yeah they think they found actually
it's whether it's a piece but or
actually it's one of the red shirts now
that's an interesting one these are the
people who have been a gangster the
government have been against the protest
from the start
they live in an area from North Point
and it was meant to be a rally there who
was stopped because so many of the
locals who are really hard many of them
linked to the triad
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know the significance of the
particular tissue and I suspect
[Applause]
I think I should point be okay that this
type of thing which should be shown on
the television live which will be being
monitored by the police and the
government isn't going to go unanswered
[Music]
[Applause]
somebody step again not least to get
whoever it is who's being who's being